the Sprint is something that you need to
design and it's the job of the Sprint
master or you in this case to plan the
activities that you're going to do
before during and after the sprint let
me give you an idea of what you can
expect in each of these periods first
you should know that you're going to
need to do a lot of work up front in
general you want to spend about one day
of planning for each day of the design
sprint now this will feel like a lot of
work and it should be the good news is
is that good planning will help you run
a smooth design sprint and let you solve
your design challenge quickly before the
design sprint you'll want to write a
design brief this will let you define
your design challenge and then it will
also let you set a timeline for when you
want to launch or for when you want this
deliverable whatever it is for the
design sprint to be reviewed before the
sprint you also want to invite team
members our talent to the sprint Nadia
will talk more about this later and one
of the key parts of a design sprint is
user testing you just schedule when
users will take a look at whatever you
create from the design sprint the user
testing will keep you accountable
validate product ideas and push you and
perhaps your team towards showing users
something by the end of the design
sprint now this might not make a whole
lot of sense right now but I guarantee
you it will by the end of this lesson
finally before the sprint you will also
want to schedule any lightning talks
more in this later and you'll want to
prep the slide deck that you'll use in
the sprint and any room in special
materials in the next video I'll cover
the details of a design brief and how
you can appropriately scope your design
challenge here are the tasks that you'll
need to do during a design sprint if
you're working alone you won't need to
do daily check-ins and daily summaries
instead you should keep a master list of
all the tasks you need to get done so
that way you can stay organized
you should also write reflections after
each day so you can look back on them
and get better at planning and designing
the sprints alone or with a team one of
the hardest parts about conducting a
design sprint is facilitating
conversation and resolving conflict
among your teammates should they arise
now you won't really need to worry about
this if you're working alone but you
will need to be the point person or
appoint someone else to resolve any
conflicts when they do arise after the
design sprint you should take the lead
to summarize the results and
plan next steps if you worked with a
team you'll want to send out a short
survey to ask your teammates about how
the design sprint went and what could go
better next time if you were working
solo then you should just reflect on
what happened and how you might improve
in the future and hopefully you'll
already be working towards planning your
next design sprint all of this should
feel like a lot of work and well it is
thankfully many other companies have
done design sprints before and there's
tons of great resources and
documentation and short articles about
how to conduct design sprints Google
Ventures for examples put together this
awesome list of resources for you they
also have a great collection a library
of resources that has short articles
that will walk you through all of the
steps needed to schedule and conduct
user research interviews these are also
your usability testing interviews that
you'll do at the end of a design spread
all of these resources will be included
in a reading node at the end of this
lesson they also have a great library of
additional resources in this library
you'll find a collection of short
articles that will walk you through all
the steps needed to schedule and conduct
user research and usability interviews
the links to these articles will be
provided in a reading node at the end of
this lesson